[Music]
in fast dude to fast-food news well but
you would fast dude to fast food Oh got
it submitted by a doctor and do me a
little the first ones who st. bolt plans
to spend his retirement building a
restaurant empire around the world
Oh what kind of food he's retiring he's
a name you know I saw the next same ball
already is this Japanese Olympian kid
well he's he's black yeah he's mixed and
the Japanese [ __ ] winning everything
he looks like Tiger Woods I think I saw
this video he beat Usain Bolt in a run I
don't know miss him there's this kid
that he's like 17 and he's he's I think
he's already like stats wise I don't
know if he raised him but he was a video
recently was some kid that are something
that ran and beat Usain Bolt
and like when it was saying camera
congratulating me like Graham just like
bow to him like I can't imagine beating
one of the fastest men in the world dude
that's amazing any girl he grew up
worshipping this guy's who that's
amazing those those races though they
their speed is on purpose so like you
know it's Olympics every four years in
between those there's World Games every
year but because those ones aren't
really important there are people that
beat you
Usain Bolt during those like his
teammate Yohan Blake beats them all the
time but it's because it doesn't matter
yeah for those they purposely it's
almost like imagine like if I'm a power
lifter right that one time a year where
me bench-pressing really matters a lot
I'm not gonna try to fry myself on all
the other races on the one that really
matters that's the one that I murder
everyone so you saying both he really uh
he says he has nothing to prove he Peaks
himself at the Olympics so a lot at the
other races he's not even beating his
record times
that's how genetically badass [ __ ]
black people are man even in Japan like
we were all like what a Japanese guy
you're like oh he's half like Oh super
crazy fast jeans and like the pride of
Japanese people are doing everything
great [ __ ] that's true look amazing
because Japanese people are [ __ ]
great at everything what I thought of
that cuz I saw this article where that
guy look like a young Tiger Woods yeah
yeah they're [ __ ] superior dude
that's crazy I wonder if someone would
one day like breaking sales records
probably as people grow more we know
because people uh one of the articles I
was reading about you saying both is uh
his speeds are so fast because he's a
genetic anomaly like he's I think is
like six four Wow usually people that
are that tall it takes a longer time for
them to take off because F their limbs
are so long so that most sprinters are
like five ten to five eleven that's the
best but the way his femur is built into
his hips he can pump them like Pistons
so he actually has the acceleration of a
510 511 guy but once the Hinch top speed
his cruising speed is that of a six four
person so when you see him race he keeps
up with everyone but once it's about
halfway through the race he just keeps
getting faster and faster
his parents should sell their sperm and
eggs see like just like surrogates be
like if you want to [ __ ] Olympian
here you go they do that I'm imagining
making an Olympian there's a there's a
there's a racehorse right now that they
let him come in a human no they look
like trying to make a save your mind
what people are paying for spring these
days [ __ ] pervert best science he's
like this championship horse and his
owners let him breathe three times a day
with like female horses there's no tire
man what if he doesn't want him he
probably has a sore horse dick but but
those female horses are brought in from
people they pay for a chance to mate
that horse it's a hundred thousand yeah
it's called like her female it's called
like stud service or something like that
so what
they do like spray perfume all over
those female horses I have no clue but
like they make so much [ __ ] money
just let their horse like bankroll
horses and people pay so much money just
to have that sperm just for a chance at
the championship reason horse yeah so
you guys asked how old Usain Bolt is you
know 31 years old older I didn't know he
was young
that's probably old in sports maybe it's
cool for a sprinter so then the next
time you'd have to be because it's every
four years right Oh 35 this year after
the 2017 World Championships he won four
medals yeah oh that's right because
people start the Olympics very young
they do very very young yeah so then now
that he's retired he wants to he wants
his restaurant called tracks and records
to be franchised and to be spread across
the world what what kind of food is it
jamaican fast casual oh so light jerk
chicken mm-hmm runaway jerk chicken yeah
so even the old branding it's like Usain
Bolt's in it tracks and records there's
that Korean Olympian that became like a
like a wrestler or something and then he
became like a comedian on TV and then he
started making those Korean barbecue
restaurants I forgot the name because
it's in Korean yeah they got a bunch of
little pension she'd go Chuck maybe it
to that one he looks like psy yeah yeah
I've been there zombies yeah use like a
wrestler I guess she kept chugging or
something and it's so good because I
don't know it's like good quality cuz
these people you know like they have
good taste yes same bubble man I want to
bring that restaurant to the LA when you
try it yes oh he opened his first
location in Kingston Jamaica Kingston in
2011 boom look like but now he wants to
franchise it and he wants to start it in
the UK opening it in London so he's
gonna be starting that up pretty cool
speaking of Jamaica I got high and I
watched a two hour or three-hour
documentary of Bob Marley on Netflix not
knowing that it was gonna be that
[ __ ] long
I just started playing the documentary
and I'm all like [ __ ] dude I think I'm
really high cuz I'm not even done with
this and it feels like I've been
watching for a long time and this is
like I think we picked a really long
documentary it was like two hours
something's good but um I really really
like like the whole Rasta religion and
what they what they're about and like
it's pretty cool I mean I hate religion
but I like that one why because they use
weed as a way to be spiritual [ __ ] and
anything that has to do with weed is
pretty cool but the other thing is like
they balance like fitness with
connecting to you know God and all this
stuff and it's kind of like a healthy
all-around thing and then the emphasis
is like love and oh no you guys start
growing out dreads bro that does not
match me but it's real appreciation okay
not in this circle alright we don't give
a [ __ ] about that [ __ ] maybe Ben can
have dreads if she wants [ __ ] or he
wants if I if I grow out my hair and
didn't do anything I wonder if it would
read I want I wonder what would happen
because my hair grows up
so it might Marge Simpson instead of
Sideshow Bob like hair down to your neck
well I had a bowl cut when I was little
but I don't know we all know now yeah
but if I wash my hair and let it just
dry it looks it just goes it just goes
off just let it grow no no yeah let's
see alright I'll do it
what is it I mean it's cold I'll [ __ ]
let it grow I mean it's starting to get
colder now from here on out it's not
cold enough I want to look like a Asian
homeless man Derrick pretty [ __ ]
close yeah yeah all my guys gonna be
awesome cuz we got September
ah DC November Joe November November
you'll see November you can make fun of
September September November where
November's were November is my favorite
cause there's Halloween November and you
guys have to watch this video it's not
out yet
fun party but yeah it's gonna be it's
gonna be on party and you guys have to
you guys have to see what Josh which
video was it again
Halloween smoothie challenge I love when
Josh plays games because I'm so
confident he's always like when he
panics and we have to play time games
he's so on it so confident that he
misses I thought I think your guys's
expression was whole and I thought that
that answer was in the bag yeah it
sounds like I did you it's a no-brainer
answer November 31st it was such
conviction you so proud to who is just
like I almost had a [ __ ] stroke dude
like that was just college game labor oh
my god yeah chicken yeah I've never had
chicken was it is I don't know think
yeah sure you see try to make it oh yeah
you love making it I'm not sure if I was
with Joe or someone else but we were in
like NorCal or the bay area and we
stopped by a jerk chicken place I want
to change your Wow yeah you were with us
but it wasn't that good oh there's
another place that was really good oh
that we did everything together
drove chicken is why did we get it in
Hawaii with what the Rasta man that had
a restaurant and it took him like three
hours to go
either you were there it was a crazy
parents when we went to keep this man
yeah we were like they really take it oh
you know there's one and I think it's
Pasadena but they're like never open
here Nelson we went there like three
times I finally saw them open and they
had just open for the night and they
were setting it up and it used to be a
church and they read it in oh that place
is haunted let me know not going
monoghan me was it good it was
forgettable we try to go there like
three times before son of a [ __ ]
but I love dried chicken sure but what
does it taste like though it's very uh
Irby oh it tastes Indian without the
Indian so it's not look I'm I'm
imagining jerky like dried hard meat
no it's juicy it's like uh oh it's kind
of like it's like kind of it's like
braised it's kind of okay I don't sound
like a doll but not adobo all right cuz
I'm speaking to you but not any Jamaican
fans know any good Jamaican restaurants
in the LA area please leave in the
comments below where we should go
because I want some legit Jamaican food
in here but leave the comment in patois
because I want Joe to have trouble
reading it now I could read it baba
Platt junior high I had a Jamaican
friend named Artie I don't know where he
went I want to find him I have a friend
who's happy to make it in half Chinese
Ora and his name is Warren Michael shim
qui very interesting name you know what
I heard there's a lot of Chinese in
Jamaica
his mom looks like the most tiniest his
mom was like the most tiniest Chinese
lady ever but when she's heard speaking
in some full-on Jamaican accent it's
funny as [ __ ] what up all my positive
people I want to hear your thoughts put
it in the comments below because if
you're negative shut the hell up and go
drink some raid please but if you're
very positive leave it in the comments
below but a last video over here